[Music]
I'm pleased to welcome to the platform
the Honorable Kenneth E Reese mayor of
the city of Cambridge welcome there I'm
also pleased to welcome to these
exercises the distinguished members of
our 50th reunion class the great class
of 1957
it is my pleasure to introduce our
commencement speaker dr. Charles M vest
MIT president emeritus professor of
mechanical engineering and
president-elect
of the National Academy of Engineering
ladies and gentlemen distinguished
guests graduates and graduates to be dr.
vest Thank You Dana
before I begin I must tell all of you
that I have listened to more
commencement speeches than you can
imagine
I've also invited more commencement
speakers to campuses than you can
imagine from this I learned that
students usually feel they were
shortchanged hypothetically now just
hypothetically they might say things
like cheese
Harvard got to bills and all we gots one
Chuck but it's okay because I want to
speak to you not to the world and
because this is MIT I'm going to talk to
you about two big things opportunity and
service here are two things I know about
opportunity first MIT is the greatest
place on the planet when it comes to
radiating education opportunity and
service second you never know when or
how opportunity will materialize don't
try to plan it or predict it because
you'll undoubtedly be wrong now how do I
know these two things about opportunity
I know them because of the two letters I
received from MIT during one twenty two
year period I received the first letter
from MIT in 90
in 68 it informed me that the Institute
was not interested in my application to
become an assistant professor
so in Ann Arbor I happily taught did
research wrote a book painted the house
helped Becky raise our children and
above all else avoided committee
assignments but 22 years later in 1990 a
second letter came from MIT this one
asked me to serve as mi t--'s president
not in my wildest dreams as a young
faculty member could I have imagined
that one day I would be called to serve
as president of this remarkable
institution so always read your mail
from MIT there's an outside chance that
instead of asking you for a donation it
may ask you to be president or perhaps
commencement speaker now being president
of MIT brought me experiences that I
could barely have dreamed of because of
the opportunities created by education
and by the place of MIT on the world
stage I would come to meet know or work
with the kings queens presidents
premiers or prime ministers of many
nations with the first human to set foot
on the moon with great artists and
musicians with the leaders of huge
corporations and with remarkable young
entrepreneurs so what happens with your
with the powerful and famous well in
2001 my wife Becky and I had tea with
Queen Elizabeth at Buckingham Palace
would you like to know what she said to
me she asked me what I thought about
Harry Potter thank goodness I had heard
enough that I knew to mumble something
about muggles and Hogwarts but believe
me it was a close call
or consider this in 1994 I found myself
in the East Room of the White House when
all the living Apollo astronauts came
together to celebrate the 25th
anniversary of the first lunar landing
as I was leaving that amazing event both
Carl Sagan and the President of the
United States sought me out to shake my
hand and thanked me personally for a
small role I had recently played in our
space program with swelled head and
adrenaline rush I floated out of the
White House to catch a taxicab then I
heard someone on the street call my name
I turned around to find a former MIT
graduate student who proceeded to berate
me with a five-minute litany of pent-up
complaints about some aspects of her
experience here she was certain that I
had been personally responsible for all
of them so there's nothing like
encountering an MIT graduate to keep
your head out of the clouds and your
feet on the ground but my real point
here is that education and MIT opened
amazing doors of opportunities to me
opportunity to learn opportunity to
teach opportunity to serve a greater
good indeed the opportunity to serve is
what I have valued above all else I had
the opportunity to serve as a voice for
science engineering and higher education
and for the importance of our nation
being open to scholars from all over the
world at a time when America sorely
needed to think about these things and I
want you to know that the people I have
most valued knowing and working with are
not the leaders of Nations or corporate
Titans they are my faculty colleagues
the intellectual leaders the teachers
and scholars who are the essence of MIT
and who give you and gave me the
opportunity to literally change
the world the opportunities for which
they the faculty have prepared you will
be as breathtaking as they are
formidable and most of them are beyond
today's imagination one reason is that
they are mostly global in scale and very
complex
another reason is the continuous
acceleration of technological progress
the future is rushing at us more quickly
every year just consider this after the
automobile was introduced it took 55
years in essence a lifetime for 25% of
the u.s. population to have a car it
took 35 years the length of a typical
career for the telephone to reach 25% of
the US population it took 23 years for
radios 16 years for the personal
computer 13 years for cell phones and
only seven years for the world wide web
do you feel the acceleration this
exponential growth well we'd better get
used to it
3,000 new books are published every day
and the amount of technical information
is doubling every two years but along
with all of this acceleration and
exploding information you have entirely
new tools many of these new tools come
from information technology or from 21st
century life science your generation is
already leading us into a new domain of
global interaction I am convinced that
your way of communicating and working
second life Wikipedia YouTube social
networking social computing open
innovation these things reflect a
fundamental transformation you can and
must guide this transformation you can
use it to make money you can use it to
revel in catching politicians and movie
stars making stupid mistakes or you can
use it to bring what James or wiki calls
wisdom of crowds to work together to
solve important problems and to build a
more inclusive engaged and more
egalitarian world society it's your
choice that's about information what
about the life sciences we are barreling
along three great frontiers of 21st
century life science and biotechnology
frontiers that present extraordinary
challenges and opportunities the first
is to realize the promise of genomic
medicine to put a powerful base of
rational science beneath the practice of
human medicine and to tailor medical
treatments to each individual patient
the second challenge is to dramatically
advance our understanding of the human
brain and mind of memory learning and
communication and to attack the mental
and emotional illnesses that today wreak
havoc on so many lives the third is to
revolutionize much of engineering using
the stuff of life as templates and using
biological mechanisms to design and grow
new materials and to create new
production techniques that mimic the
efficiency of nature thereby greatly
reducing the environmental footprint
left by industry or to cite a more
prosaic example last year researchers
announced that they had cloned pigs that
made their own omega-3 fatty acid
imagine on the horizon is health food
sausage and there's more already the
term biohacking is heard along our
infinite corridor biohacking just think
about the significance of that term it
of course heralds the advent of
synthetic biology the fusion of
engineering and biology to design and
build novel biological functions and
systems we'll all of these new
capabilities of information science life
science engineering and their
combination be used for
good or for ill how will you grapple
with the ethical and legal questions
that will come along with these new
powers
how will you influence the public
discourse and the public action on these
questions these are enormous challenges
in part because technological
advancement usually outpaced the social
advancement for example the design of
the Internet that forms the basis of so
much opportunity in the world today was
predicated on mutual trust trust that
you are who you say you are and that you
are doing what you say you were doing
but now of course we have viruses worms
and phishing that's P H is H ing you
guys will have to explain to your
parents what that means but these human
developed technological evils can be
very serious just a couple of week ago
weeks ago hackers virtually brought down
the cyber structure of an entire nation
Estonia this is a highly wired country
and it's government business and economy
were very seriously impacted because of
all of this colleagues tell me that the
internet must now be redesigned with
security rather than trust at its core
and we are all aware of the debates
around genetic counseling stem cells and
genetic modification of crops and foods
such redesigns and such debates are a
necessary part of life in a free society
but you must be prepared to engage in
the public dialogue and bring your own
moral compasses and your commitments to
applying the rationality of science and
engineering to improving the human
condition but let me turn the clock back
fifty years each of us has a few moments
of seemingly random memories of the past
that from time to time spring into our
minds with full clarity of sight sound
and feelings when such memory for me is
simply of walking to high school one
sunny morning in 1957 I lived only two
houses away from high school so if I
left home when I heard the first bell
ring I could make it into my seat before
the second bell but be that as it may I
remember on that day a feeling of
absolute joy well-being good fortune and
optimism the air was warm and clear the
American flag was fluttering in front of
the school the sky was blue and the sky
was the limit life was good the fact is
that joy well being good fortune and
optimism were the right things for me to
feel life indeed was good if you were a
boy growing up middle class and white
and an American college town in the
1950s now much water has flowed over the
proverbial dam in the years since then
but you know what I still believe that
optimism was very well founded now you
may say yes but when you were young your
world was much simpler and certainly
more insular than ours today we face
incredible global challenges we have to
improve the world's health economies
security and quality of life we have to
provide water and food for the
burgeoning peoples of the earth we have
to give them clean air to breathe and
clear blue skies to make their spirits
soar we have to provide the energy that
will lessen their burdens integrate them
into the world community and give them
economic opportunity we have to cure
their ills and safeguard their
well-being come on now we have a much
harder road than you did why should we
be optimistic well in some ways you are
right but I want to leave you with
another perspective when I was young I
sat in our comfortable home in front of
a black-and-white television and watched
an interview with dr. Tom Dooley
an American medical doctor serving
people in Asia in the midst of
unfathomable poverty and dire living
conditions dr. Dooley held up in front
of the camera
a tiny ill starving child with distended
belly now I have to explain that in
1950s such sites were never seen on
television or even in magazines it was
shocking and I recoiled emotionally then
he calmly said in essence when you look
at this child you see something
horrifying but I look at this child and
know that I have the knowledge and the
skill to make him well I believe that
simple statement is a metaphor for what
the graduates of a great university
especially one with the focus of MIT can
and must do make the world well yes you
do grasp the complexity of our world and
you understand the enormity of its
challenges but you also have new tools
to resolve them in the end I believe
that knowledge and skill Trump ignorant
and that optimism Trump's pessimism if
you believe this and if you embrace the
opportunity to serve you will find
personal happiness and fulfillment
beyond expectation and you will benefit
our world and your fellow men and women
beyond measure good luck and Godspeed
you